New York Times best-selling author
Daniel H pink says regrets should not be
ignored his latest book is the power of
regret how Looking Backward moves us
forward pink writes this it is healthy
and Universal an integral part of Being
Human regrets is also valuable can lift
us up so says Daniel pink Daniel pink
joins us at the table it's good to see
you thank you hello Mr Pink you said
it's the most misunderstood emotion you
said it can give us hope and make us
better and a lot of people went huh what
you think about Willis so how do you
explain that well regret is one of the
most common emotions that human beings
have it's that sinking terrible feeling
that we get when we look backward and
say ah if only I had done this today
would be better it is
as common as any emotion that human
beings experience everybody has regrets
the only people who don't have regrets
even though a lot of us say I don't have
any regrets I never look back with the
only people who truly don't have regrets
are five-year-olds because their brains
haven't developed enough people with
certain kinds of neurodegenerative
diseases and sociopaths everybody else
has regrets but you also break it down
uh
I just want to hit the forecast for
categories very quickly because I think
that'll be a good foundation for the
conversation four categories quickly
Foundation is what Foundation regrets
our regrets that people have but small
decisions early that accumulate to bad
consequences later I spent too much in
saved too little now I'm broke boldness
um I didn't take a chance I was at a
juncture in my life I could play it safe
or I could take the chance I didn't ask
somebody out on a date I didn't start
the business I didn't do something big
and bold a little moral
I have two I had a choice in life I
could take the low road or take the high
road I took the low road I bullied I
cheated on my spouse and now I regret it
it's the smallest regret but it's also
the most painful connection
um it's about reaching out to people we
care about so I have an old I have an
old friend wow I haven't talked to him
for a few years I should really reach
out no it's going to be awkward he's not
going to care so I wait a few more years
and sometimes it's too late yeah here's
the thing people don't like the emotion
of regret they don't get the feeling and
so they avoid it when people avoid it
and they're not in touch with this what
do they lose they lose incredible
benefits we know from 50 years of social
science that if we confront our regrets
don't ignore them but also don't wallow
on them it can help us become better
negotiators better problem solvers
better strategists better thinkers find
more meaning in life I mean we have 50
years of science showing us that if we
treat our regrets as signals as
information it makes us better so this
so it's there for a reason Tony like
like there's a reason you know regret
feels terrible and yet it's Universal
I'm with you I wonder if I wallow or if
I confront what's the line between the
two right that is a fine line uh you
write that the most common regrets in
2021 family Partners education career
Finance Health friends and other but you
also suggest making a list of your old
regrets this is the time of the year for
it yeah absolutely because one of the
best ways to make a New Year's
resolutions is to think about your old
year regret and so what I would suggest
is this is a moment right now where
we're looking back on the year so we can
look back on the year and say oh if only
I'd done that if only I had done that
and we can say no no no no no no I don't
want to be negative or you can say wow I
feel bad about that find one thing that
you wish you had done one thing you wish
you hadn't done and use that as the
foundation of your New Year's resume
oftentimes there's some parallels that
happen with my old career in the career
I'm in and now and it reminds me of
playing football you come off a game you
lose you don't play well yeah you create
a game plan for your next opponent
you're saying know what your mistakes
were our next opponent is 2023. so you
go into that year with a game plan sure
and when your strengths and weaknesses
maximize your strengths minimize your
weaknesses how's the game tape exactly I
was going to say I was going to see you
and raise you it's about watching it's
about watching the game film yeah we
don't say you don't say in professional
sports or any kind of high performance
Endeavor I don't look back at my
performance you look back on your
performance and you don't you don't say
oh I stink I'm terrible person ever or
you don't say don't you don't blind
yourself to it you say whoa
I can learn something from this you also
talk about kudas and shoulders and I
think this is very relatable what's the
difference couldn't shut up well could
have or regrets that we have about sort
of how we fell short to uh of
opportunities all right oh I could have
started a business I could have asked
out Marlene 20 years ago Marlene
she could be watching now should us are
about our obligations uh I should have
been kinder to my to my brother I should
have I should as you can fix could it
can't right that's hugely important and
it's uh we can fix our shoulders the
other thing is that one of the things
that sticks with people Gail are regrets
of inaction regrets of action are far
less common than regrets of inaction
what we regret over time is what we
didn't do especially things about
reaching out to people we care about and
and being bold taking that challenge so
that's where the No Regrets slogan
actually works if it encourages action
if it encourages action sort of I'm
trying to avoid big regrets in the
future which one action could lead to
right exactly exactly but what some
people do with the no regrets philosophy
is they say I don't have any regrets
right now because I always want to be
positive and I never want to look
backward and that's not a recipe for a
good life do men and women have
different regrets generally speaking
um some men have more such regrets and
women have such regrets men tend to have
more regrets about career women have
more regrets about about about family
there's also this is not this is not
I'll tell you this is not this is not my
research but there is there is there is
there is research out there it's in a
footnote in the book um it probably
should have put it in the main text that
shows essentially that their differences
in sexual regrets so that as to make it
to oversimplify but not by much
um women regret the people they slept
with men regret the people they didn't
sleep with ah what regrets do you have
Daniel 18 well speaking to the
microphone well not since Marlene and my
my wife are likely watching I'm going to
I have regret scale really about
kindness earlier in my life when I was a
younger guy
um I was I was never a bully and and you
were mean what you know what I was mean
through in action it was it was strange
that I was in situations where people
were not being treated well they were
being left out they were being excluded
and I knew it was wrong and I didn't do
anything and that has bugged me for 10
years 20 years without standard regret
the question is what do I do with that
yeah what do you do with that and write
a book yeah but you put it out but you
put it out there and someone is
listening what does the h stand for in
Daniel H pink Howard Howard all right
Daniel Howard pink we think thank you
the power of regret is on sale now
wherever you like to buy your books